Walking under the vibrant
sky and rustic
cliffs of Cap Rock Canyon State
feels like a journey into a lost
In this corner of West Texas,
this sprawling land is home
to a herd of southern plains bis
a species
that centuries ago
dominated the landscape.
Today,
it's a park
where the bison and the humans r
So this is kind of just my
memory wall.
Last month,
Rebecca Clark visited the park
for a week of solo hiking.
That's actually him.
She didn't think the experience
would end up immortalized on thi
I want to remember that time
and all the things that happen.
It's a story she's lucky to tell
Come on, keep going.
I just want to get back. Okay.
Clark recorded on her phone
as she crossed paths
with bison roaming past a trail
closer than the 50 yard minimum
distance recommended.
At what point did you realize
you were in trouble?
Well, I think it's when
I use profanity in my video.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
When I saw him
turn it's like,
instantly I knew
he was going to come after me.
Oh, no.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
The bison gored Clark in the bac
It was so fast.
He hit me in the back,
ran to me, hooked me,
and then flipped me up
face for the in to the mesquite
What is going through your mind
at that time?
I was paralyzed.
You've kept the backpack intact.
Oh, yes.
This is my backpack.
I might wash it eventually.
I had to eat a lot of humble pie
for this one.
The bison's horn
cut a wide gash in her back.
I still know that I was too clos
You know,
I wasn't as diligent
as I should have been.
Clark posted her video on Tik To
It went viral,
and it also put the spotlight
on this unique state park.
The Lobos are definitely
the keystone species.
Donald Beard
is the superintendent of Cap
Rock Canyon State Park
and a passionate advocate
of growing bison herd population
across the country.
It's really cool to be able
to drive through this park
and have bison walk
across the road
in front of you
and see them
and know the history of them.
In the 1870s,
the Texas bison were decimated
in the great slaughter.
But famed ranchers Charles and M
good night saved a few.
The descendants of those
bison were bred
and kept on a private ranch for
In 2011, the park released the b
to begin
roaming freely through much of t
15,000 acre park Since then, Bea
the herd grew from 80 animals to
The song
Give Me a Home Where the buffalo
That's where we live.
Visitors are warned
repeatedly to keep their distanc
The bison are king
They are survivors.
You know,
they've survived our best attemp
at trying to get rid of them.
And they're making a comeback.
Has this changed your relationsh
with this animal?
I'm sorry.
Gosh,
we can't believe you did this to
I tried to protect the opportuni
to go experience nature.
This is what makes Rebecca
Clark emotional.
She'd be devastated if her encou
prevents others
from this Bison experience.
Do you love the outdoors that mu
No, I think that.
Yeah. Wow.
I'm so sorry.
Now, you said aha moment for me
either, so. Yeah,
I hope I didn't
Yeah.
Somebody else from that.